Foods we need it to survive
say maybe it's not surprising that many
fix their daily routine and work
schedule around it where is Bard anyway
because dinner is getting all cold and
eaten while many like to discuss the
quantity and quality of a diet
one factor I also think is important is
when so given a couple of recent trials
have looked into this I thought it was
time to talk about time and feed timing
and food consumption I mean of course
and the papers generally seem to reach a
similar conclusion so let's take a quick
look through them see what they did
address the limitations and discuss what
it all means
but firstly why might timing of food
consumption be important
well one word that's associated with
timing is the word Rhythm and in music
that's about the placements of sounds
and time
or in biology the regulated succession
of molecular and physiological offense I
am of course talking about the Circadian
rhythm the around 24-hour oscillation
that can be found at the molecular
physiological and behavioral level of
nearly all living organisms including us
so this includes things such as
behavioral rhythms of the digestive
system cardiovascular system immune
system and reproductive system
the daily Rhythm is a complex interplay
of an endogenous cell autonomous as a
proteins that oscillate an activity and
expression with respect to daily
exposure to light and dark and of
relevance to this video feeding and
fasting
why this daily oscillation is necessary
is thought to be for a few reasons
this includes being able to anticipate
light dark Cycles
being able to separate and compatible
biochemical or physiological processes
and optimizing energy expenditure and
preventing buildup of toxic
intermediates and metabolic pathways
the problem is for many of us now
exposure to artificial lighting and
access to foods are available 24 7.
and this puts us at risk of so-called
circadian dissonance
when are different clocks are out of
sync
but unfortunately this is best
documented in shift workers where
chronic circadian disruption has put
them at increased risk of chronic
diseases associated with aging
but with these studies there are many
confounding factors such as different
sleep and activity levels throughout the
day
as it's not just the timing of feed
intake that's changing her
so as I already mentioned this phrases
the question as to whether there is an
optimal time to eat
well Sachin panzo is one of the many
researchers now who are interested in
addressing this question
it's been a while now since I read his
book the Circadian codes but that was
where I first learned about his research
on time restricted feeding while you
limit food intake to a specific time
window of 9 to 12 hours
having isocaloric time restricted
feeding studies in rodents have
suggested improvements in several
metabolic parameters including glucose
and Insulin homeostasis energy
production liver pathology and
resistance to different abusogenic diets
there was also a paper that showed that
that the time restructured feeding
pattern extended lifespan and improved
age-related Health outcomes in mice but
the study I think also had an impact on
the amount of food that the mice were
taking so can't really distinguish
between the two
and as with this last time I'll study
some human Studies have been done but
it's also impacted calorie intake
sort of appears to be some sort of
scientific backing to the importance of
when food is eaten but there hasn't been
that many studies that have directly
compared within the same group how
adjusting eating windows from early to
late changes different biomarkers
many epidemiological Studies have
Associated skipping breakfast with
increased risk for cardiovascular
disease cancer and overall mortality
but again there are just many
confounding variables and we can't
really take too much from these
epidemiological studies
and so that is until now where I'm going
to talk about three different recent
Publications that have at least to some
extent try to account for these caveats
so the first paper lates ISO caloric
eating increases hunger decreases energy
expenditure and modifies metabolic
pathways in adults with overweight
and obesity
so I was kind of given away by that
title
this paper aimed to investigate the
Direct effects of meal timing without
confounding by other behavioral and
environmental factors
so they controlled for timing amount and
type of food intake
so total caloric intake and dietary
composition physical activity posture
not quite sure what they mean by that
sleep and light exposure and they had 16
participants with overweight or obesity
and each participant completed the two
protocols either an early eating
protocol
or a late eating protocol where Mills
were delayed by 250 minutes
so one of the things they looked at was
the effects of late eating on two
appetite regulating hormones leptin
which promotes satiety so tells the body
that it's full up and a sea slated
ghrelin which promotes hunger
these hormones were assessed hourly
across 24 hours throughout each of their
test days
the late eating protocol decreased
24-hour leptin Levels by six percent and
increased the 24-hour ghrelin leptin
ratio by 12 percent
and so the authors concludes that the
late eating protocol increased hunger
because as there was a greater ratio of
ghrelin to leptin
compared to the early eating protocol
because ghrelin promotes hunger so
bearing that conclusion in mind let's
move on to paper number two timing of
daily calorie loading effects appetites
and hunger responses without changes in
energy metabolism in healthy subjects
with obesity
so similarly here they were looking at
hunger and energy metabolism
this time in 30 overweight obese adults
so slightly different this time they had
a four-week randomized crossover trial
where they had a morning loaded diet
versus an evening loaded diet so the
timings were the same it's just they ate
more of their calories either in the
morning or the evening as you can see
here
and so the individual calorie intake was
fixed
and at least according to the authors
since all food and beverages were
provided it made it the most rigorously
controlled study to assess timing of
eating in humans to date with the aim of
accounting for all aspects of energy
balance
and so their main finding was that
morning load energy intake resulted in
lower daily subjective appetite and
hunger matching the first study but here
they didn't see any difference in energy
metabolism between the morning loaded
versus the evening loaders
they also didn't see any significant
differences between the two groups when
they looked at changes in glucose
insulin and blood lipid profiles
I say the reason that I mentioned these
last sort of measurements is that this
brings us on to the third study
randomized control trial for
time-restricted eating in healthy
volunteers without obesity
whether somebody looked at healthy
individuals over a five-week randomized
trial comparing early versus mid-time
restricted feeding the early time
restricted feeding including an eight
hour period between 6 a.m and 3pm whilst
the mid had a eight hour window between
11AM and 8pm
and then they were comparing the data to
a free eating control group
these are just some of the results on
energy intake and metabolic health
related parameters and just focusing on
early versus mids you can see how
there's a slightly lower energy intake
with the early group but the only other
significant change was in this Interline
resistance index that is calculated
based on fasting glucose and insulin and
concentrations but there was an
improvement in the early eating group
and for each of these data points this
is the change over five weeks
so Benjamin Franklin is famous for
saying to lengthen their life lessened
by Mills
for many to adopt an earlier time eating
window it is likely that an evening meal
would have to be sacrificed
but to be frank not Franklin the more I
think about it the more I realize just
how hard it is to really control in
studies like this and all the
limitations that come with it obviously
these are small scale studies only done
for short time periods
plus there's the fact that the processes
that are being investigated are also
tightly connected to the Circadian
rhythm and so thinking about how timing
of measurements are affecting things
how to stringently control for sleeping
patterns the period of fasting between
when that person ate and when that
measurement was taken
and then it also raises many other
questions like what would happen if they
looked long-term would there be
adaptation to a dietary pattern
are there genetic contributions to this
relating to chronotype so when someone
naturally sleeps are there age-specific
differences
how much do these findings depend on the
diet composition maybe it's better to
eat certain types of foods at different
times of the day and how could this
information potentially help shift
workers
also none of these studies really try to
address the molecular mechanism for
these results
and there's a lot of interesting work
that shows that the metabolites that
obviously we get from Foods feedback
onto the course circadian clock or and
also the fact that the clock regulates
expression of metabolic genes
and so it would be interesting to see if
we could actually work out if early
eating did resonate more with circadian
consonants instead of causing circadian
dissonance
and so I don't give dietary advice I'm
only a research scientist who likes to
read papers that I find interesting and
obviously there are a lot of limitations
in these studies and even if all three
studies reach similar conclusions they
all have limitations
that said it does seem to fit with our
biological understanding of circadian
rhythms it's just hard to conclude much
from these papers
nonetheless it's nice to see that
researchers are investigating this topic
as from my still naive understanding of
the Circadian rhythm I think timing
really does have an impact on how our
bodies responds
so that's I hope you found something
interesting from this video thank you to
my patreon supporters and thank you